this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today as it's been easily one of our
most
requested titles jonathan is going to be
breaking down the weaponry
of insurgency sandstorm gaming is not
just about uh firearms of course
some sort of launcher is a staple of
most shooters this game features
the rpg-7 quite a good depiction i
thought
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan react to
do let us know in the comments below and
make sure to subscribe for videos
exactly like this and if you want to
help out the royal armies museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
then please check out the links in the
description of this video
right over to jonathan
pause i did not expect a
first-person shooter set in the present
day to feature
a second world war silence pistol which
is the well rod
i'm sure your people already know now
they did
get used after the second world war i
don't know how late
certainly not as late as the 2010s so
it's it's kind of anachronistic to see
one in use
in this pseudo-realistic military
setting and it really doesn't make much
sense to be
running and gunning with this thing like
it's a rifle
i've never seen one with any kind of
rail
welded or otherwise attached to it um
they predate that kind of
accessorization and you would want to
keep them
slim and compact anyway in terms of how
it's depicted
as a model it's a weird hybrid of the
mark
ii 32 acp version and the
mark one nine millimeter they're
effectively two different series in the
different calibers
and we have the only mark 1 32 by the
way
at the royal armouries which is a an
actual mini bolt action
this thing has like a disc bolt that you
grasp rotate
pull back shove forward rotate again and
that's depicted pretty pretty accurately
here
here is a nine millimeter um mach one
well rod so just to prove the point that
this is actually pretty well depicted
rotate pull out empty cartridge case
would be thrown out
you see the two lugs there that lock the
gun shut push forward
turn to lock that's then copped the
striker inside
and when we press the grip safety which
is what this is
you can then pull the trigger to fire
the gun one of the best subjectively
suppressed firearms ever created and
still as
quiet as a modern suppressed pistol but
that's the problem
because a modern self-loading pistol
with a
screw-on or other attachable suppressor
or detachable suppressor
pretty much as quiet as this and you get
more than five shots
and you don't have to work a bolt so
this thing was obsolete
by the 1960s if not before
[Applause]
paul's there then we've got an uzi like
all sub machine guns it's a bit out of
fashion these days it's
relatively heavy for what it is look
pretty good to me i don't really
understand the
um competition style cooking handle
that's fitted to it i'm not seeing that
done before on an uzi i'm not really
sure why you'd bother but it's not
implausible
and a sort of bodged on vertical
foregrip otherwise it's
standard oozing from the from the 50s
which we happen to have
an example of here and it looks pretty
good three fire
control settings automatic repetition
and safe
and it's a pistol cartridge so i i
imagine the damage model in the game
reflects the fact that it is a weaker
cartridge
the mark iv or the l2 a3 mark iv is
sterling's in-house
designation for the same gun l283 was
the definitive british
army version of this nine millimeter
submachine gun that we've just seen in
that clip i've grabbed this one
primarily because i'm slightly aghast at
the
um welded on picatinny rail that the
game has on the top of the gun
i'm not even sure that would work
because the
receiver is being a tube first of all is
is curved obviously so you'd have some
company would have to design you a
picatinny rail
attachment and it's also very narrow
because there's the cocking handle slot
so it would
a picatinny rail i think would be
slightly too
wide to even fit for me it's the
principle of
if you're going to have a cool sort of
legacy
retro gun in the game why would you ruin
it
by adding modern features like that i
didn't spot how um
how it's functioning but it should be
operating from the open bolt
in that position there pull the trigger
bang
bolt blows back and continues to move
the finger down i'm still pleased to see
it in a video game don't get me wrong
but it'd be nice if it was in its
original trim
we've got another mp5 this one that i've
grabbed is
it's an sd the suppressed version which
is what we saw
being used just then i quite like the
way that one was depicted
i'm a connoisseur of video game mp5s
and that one pretty much nailed the mp5
in general and the sd
specifically the sound effects are not
far off what you actually hear in real
life
when you shoot this thing or you hear
this thing shot people often say
it's so quiet all you hear is the bolt
clicking back and forth which is
mostly true slight pop from the muzzle
the loud clang of the bolt
moving you're going to know something's
going on but you might not know that
it's a firearm
and this was for decades was the
default definitive suppressed submachine
gun wasn't really worth using anything
else provided you could afford this
executing me
okay pause i often say that you can't
have a
certainly a first person shooter without
a kalashnikov
variant in there somewhere in fact what
i'd expect would like to see
would be lots of different variants
looks like a decent representation of
the akm
we've got the correct russian style
sight mount riveted to the side of the
receiver rather than some
made-up rail system on the top cover
which would wouldn't really work with a
normal ak
so that's a good compromise of
accessorization without
changing the classic look of the gun
there has been a
choice to include or the version of the
akm that's in the game
is the romanian md63 which is an akm
in all but name except for markings but
also it's distinctive
forward curved wooden grip which is
ergonomically
quite tricky because it does affect how
the magazine
goes on as a relatively early attempt at
a vertical core grip it does help
to control automatic fire a lot of ak's
historically been
used like a submachine gun pulling down
on that like a thompson pool grip is
was a valid way to use it
the sa-80 has been a feature of desert
warfare for
the last couple of decades it's good to
see different nations
weapons represented in that way being
british and a
firearms specialist i have a weird sort
of blood-paid relationship with the s90
i've just written a book that includes
several chapters on on the difficult
story of how it came to be
the one i've got in my hands here is
almost identical in fact i think it is
identical except for the vertical grip
to the weapon as it's depicted in
insurgency the optical
sight is the susat four power optic
again that's
if this is if assuming this is set in
the sort of mid to late 2000s
that's correct they're all now painted a
desert sand colour as well incidentally
appropriately for this game although the
game depicts the old style black painted
version which is what i have here
nitpicks well um you don't slap the
bolts release with your palm of your
hand like you were in ar15 and like
as is depicted in insurgents and
sandstorm you simply press it
i think someone has seen that catch and
assume that it's a press
like a lever as it is on the ar which it
isn't um
the other big one which i think i'm
writing saying is the case there's
safety there's no safety depicted on the
weapon
this is the safety uh it's not an awful
setup
um it does you do need the other hand to
apply the safety
but if you're applying a safety you're
generally not in the face of the enemy
it works the way that matters which is
when you're ready for action you press
it in and then
bring your finger to the trigger
okay that's a pause g36 standard
german army rifle and the version in the
game
has the ag-36 grenade launcher fitted to
it
press the button in the trigger guard
and the tube pops out to the side
for loading that means in theory you can
load longer cartridges
pretty well depicted i think um the
sights the grenade sights
are on there flip up the rear with your
thumb flip up the front
and it gives you the extreme elevation
that you need to
lob these low velocity grenade rounds
another take on the very common ar-15
platform
we've actually got two versions of the
m16 in this game and this one has got
this a4
has the master key under
shotgun fitted to it which i've seen in
a few games over the years
it's a lot of fun gameplay-wise because
you're combining the the
short-range devastation you get from a
video game shotgun with low magazine
capacity and
pump reload with the capability of a
rifle it's
not that the name is a clue as to what
it was actually bought it wasn't for
shooting people with
master key as in one key that will let
you in all the doors
it's for knocking doors down or rather
blowing the hinges away so that you can
kick the door down
now it's not to say that um it couldn't
be used or wouldn't be used for shooting
people with imagine if you
use it to blow a door down you might not
necessarily switch to the rifle
and it was never never a standard issue
accessory
the pkm it looks like a well-modeled
example of the pkm
that i saw tracer actually trace the
fire we often now almost always see
a version of trace of fire to really
indicate where fire's coming from
where your fire is going in a video game
sense that looked a bit more realistic
in terms of it's a green color there is
green red
tracer tracer is usually a bright
primary color not
generic bullet orange so the developers
are trying to go for a bit more realism
otherwise bullets should be invisible
you shouldn't see them zipping through
the air
unless it's disturbing the atmosphere
with my very long range shot
i just want to comment quickly on the in
a positive sense
on the ammunition management system that
i see in this game
other tactical shooters that i've played
i always appreciate if
they model ammunition fire from a
magazine or just
in some cases um boxes of belted
ammunition
whatever the feed device is it makes you
think and it changes
which is gameplay realistic and i think
less fun i think if you have to remember
what's in your magazines
certainly for a tactical themed game it
makes it more enjoyable
all right pause an interesting
substitute for the barrett i think
in this case the chinese m99
anti-materiel rifle not much is known
about the m99s
and its capabilities so i don't know if
it's less accurate than the barrett
it does differ in terms of being
gas-operated it has a conventional
ish gas system on it which might well
contribute to less accuracy hard to say
speculation really and so it's kind of
um
it's interesting to see it in the game
it's probably the only game it's ever
been depicted
in and thanks to the internet we're able
to
get enough images to to depict it in a
way that looks realistic but i don't
know
how realistically it actually is
depicted
gaming is not just about uh firearms of
course
um some sort of launcher is a staple of
most shooters
this game features the rpg-7 as many
others have
quite a good depiction i thought i
removed the the warhead or munition
it's not a grenade not at least not by
western standards you can see it does
look very very similar
in terms of loading something a lot of
games get wrong but this game doesn't
is this doesn't screw in this just sits
in place
it's held by friction by a washer and
there's a screw here that you locate
into the
groove and you just it's just a friction
bit
iron sights on this for emergencies
designed to use the
um the optical sight and a very
effective unguided
anti-tank anti-vehicle anti-structure
weapon
i hope you've enjoyed watching this
breakdown of some of the weapons
of insurgency sandstorm if you'd like to
donate to the royal armouries museum or
to become a member we have got links in
the description
no pressure at all i just hope you
enjoyed the video hope to see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you